buongiorno oggi vi parlerò del mio
contributo nella gestione dell'emergenza
cove 19 in particolare parlerò di alcuni
algoritmi che abbiamo sviluppato per
aiutare i medici nella valutazione del
dato ultrasonografica partiamo dal
titolo di questo intervento ascoltare
l'invisibile invisibile è qualcosa che
non può essere visto ovvero rilevato
attraverso la vista ma la vista è
soltanto uno dei nostri sensi air
infatti noi siamo in grado di percepire
di rilevare un qualcosa anche
utilizzando un altro e se anzi a nostra
disposizione oppure utilizzando uno
strumento diverso dai nostri sensi
ma andiamo per gradi ora quando parliamo
di vista si pensa immediatamente
un'immagine quella che vedete adesso è
l'immagine di una ultrasonografia
prenatale quella cosa che avete sempre
sentito chiamare ecografia
qua si può chiaramente vedere e
riconoscere diverse strutture anatomiche
come la struttura cranica si vede
sostanzialmente subito che ha un bambino
quando pensiamo dunque all'immagine di
un polmone
ci aspetteremmo di vedere qualcosa di
simile a questa immagine questa invece è
l'immagine ecografica di un polmone
in questo caso non è sostanzialmente
possibile visualizzare vedere con
chiarezza una rappresentazione fedele
dell'organo appunto del polmone facciamo
adesso un piccolo passo indietro e
cerchiamo di capire un po meglio come
vengono realizzate queste immagini come
dicevamo si tratta di ultrasonografia
realizzate e dunque con una tecnologia
che utilizza appunto gli ultrasuoni per
realizzare un'immagine adesso gli
ultrasuoni sono semplicemente suoni che
non possono però essere percepiti dal
nostro sistema uditivo
perché a frequenze troppo elevate in
natura esistono però esempi di altre
creature che sono in grado di ascoltare
questi suoni e in grado anche di
produrre questi suoni in particolare tra
i cetacei
sembra che il capodoglio tramite un
processo definito di ecolocalizzazione
produca e successivamente ascolti questi
suoni ad alta frequenza e che proprio
grazie alla rielaborazione di questi
suoni di questi segnali riesca a
costruirsi una mazza un'immagine di
quello che lo circonda il capodoglio
sfrutta in particolare questa tecnica
per localizzare cacciare i calamari
giganti nell'oscurità delle profondità
marine di fatto e quindi in grado di
ascoltare e quindi rilevare l'invisibile
questo stesso concetto il concetto di
eco localizzazione è alla base delle
ecografie
in questo caso non sarà però il
capodoglio a trasmettere e ricevere gli
ultrasuoni
ma diversamente una sonda collegata poi
a strumenti dedicati alla raccolta
elaborazione del dato ai fini di creare
un'immagine torniamo per un momento
all'immagine del feto qua come si diceva
si riesce a distinguere con chiarezza le
strutture anatomiche e si può per
esempio stimare con relativa facilità la
circonferenza cranica
questa misura quantitativa ripetuta poi
nel tempo ci può aiutare a capire lo
stato di salute e di sviluppo del feto
nel polmone
la situazione è invece alquanto diversa
a causa della presenza dell'area anche
complica la propagazione degli
ultrasuoni all'interno del polmone non
si riesce infatti a ricostruire
quell'immagine anatomica che vorremmo
tanto vedere in questo caso anche
utilizzando gli ultrasuoni l'anatomia
del polmone rimane quindi invisibile
questo come ben capite complica di gran
lunga l'utilizzo
ultrasonografia nella diagnosi delle
malattie polmonari ed è proprio qui che
si inserisce il lavoro del laboratorio
di ultrasuoni di trento come abbiamo
accennato nella premessa il fatto che
una cosa ci risulta invisibile non deve
farci pensare che non si possa riuscire
comunque ad osservarla a studiarla a
capirla
ora a partire dagli anni 90 i medici
hanno iniziato a utilizzare
l'ultrasonografia per guardare al
polmone ed hanno scoperto come nel caso
di particolari patologie
le immagini ultrà sono grafiche
cambiassero presentassero degli strani
segni si poteva in sostanza classificare
questi segni in base all'esperienza
clinica e sfruttarli a fini diagnostici
qua vedete per esempio la tipica
immagine di un polmone sun durante
un'ecografia la sonda che trasmette e
riceve gli ultrasuoni è posizionata
sulla pelle e guarda ovviamente verso il
polmone
quello che vedete nella parte alta
dell'immagine rappresenta
sostanzialmente i tessuti intercostali
quello che c'è tra la sonda ed il
polmone
subito dopo subito sotto trovate la
parte dell'immagine che in qualche modo
è rappresentativa del polmone
come avevamo anticipato un polmone sano
e piano d aria ed è sostanzialmente
impenetrabile impenetrabile agli
ultrasuoni si comporta un po come uno
specchio
quello che si vede dunque nell'immagine
ecografica e in qualche modo simile a
quello che si osserverebbe scattando una
fotografia vicino a degli specchi una
continua riflessione riproduzione di una
parte dell'immagine infatti
nell'immagine del polmone sano si nota
con chiarezza la presenza di queste
linee orizzontali che sono
sostanzialmente delle ripetizioni
distorte dell'immagine dei tessuti
intercostali
e della linea plough rica diversamente
nel caso di un'alterazione anche lieve
della superficie del polmone si iniziano
invece a vedere dei segni come questo
che si possono definire artefatti
verticali e che di fatto segnalano la
presenza di una qualche alterazione
adesso queste immagini sono esempi
chiari ben distinguibili ma non è sempre
così semplice fare una distinzione
inoltre spesso i medici devono fare
valutazioni in tempi molto brevi e
potrebbe risultare per loro complicato
rivedere molte immagini in un breve
tempo non è detto inoltre che medici
diversi giungano alla stessa conclusione
ed è qui che si innesta un primo
tassello del lavoro che stiamo svolgendo
in particolare nel supporto della
valutazione del dato oltre sono grafico
in pazienti affetti da kobe 19 per
raggiungere una riproducibilità elevata
e fare sostanzialmente in modo il più
possibile che medici diversi giungano
alla stessa conclusione qualora
valutassero il dato ottenuto da uno
stesso paziente
la prima essenziale cosa da fare è
standardizzare il protocollo di
acquisizione del dato e standardizzare
anche la modalità di valutazione dello
stesso per prima cosa è importante
definire dove osservare qua vedete per
esempio l'indicazione dei punti di
osservazione che abbiamo messo appunto
durante l'emergenza covi 19
si tratta di 14 punti ben definiti
distribuiti sul torace
serve poi capire come valutare questi
dati
qua vedete per esempio il nostro sistema
di valutazione su quattro livelli
proposto per il copy 19 diverse immagini
e diversi livelli di score associati
alla gravità dell'alterazione della
superficie polmonare
più alto il livello di score più alta è
l'alterazione queste immagini possono
pensate essere realizzate con strumenti
portati
della dimensione di un telefono una
volta stabiliti poi questi punti di
partenza chiari si può procedere
all'implementazione di questa
metodologia quello che vedete qua adesso
è un video più o meno così come si
presenterebbe oggi agli occhi di un
dottore
ebbene adesso il dottore dovrebbe essere
in grado di valutarlo e ricordatevi che
ve ne sono 14 di questi video per ogni
paziente e che stiamo parlando ad oggi
di decine di migliaia di nuovi positivi
ogni giorno quello che abbiamo
sviluppato sono quindi una serie di
algoritmi in grado di fare questa
valutazione per il medico in un tempo
molto veloce attraverso questi algoritmi
il medico potrà avere una prima
valutazione del dato oltre sono grafico
in termini di livello di gravità
dell'alterazione ed avere anche una
spiegazione
infatti attraverso delle mappe di colore
che indicano le parti importanti delle
immagini insieme a livello di gravità
associato riscontrato dalla macchina
il medico avrà a disposizione in
pochissimi secondi una valutazione del
dato la valutazione finale resta
comunque al medico che potrà adesso però
usufruire appunto di questo supporto
importante
questi algoritmi sono attualmente
disponibili in modo gratuito tramite
un'applicazione web che produce anche un
semplice referto che indica la
valutazione e la distribuzione dei
livelli di gravità
relativamente ai 14 punti di misura
considerate che il tempo di valutazione
è di soli pochi secondi
ci tengo poi a precisare come questo sia
il risultato di uno sforzo
multidisciplinare che è stato possibile
grazie al contributo di moltissime
persone professori ingegneri medici e
studenti con un ampio spettro di
competenze e che rappresentano nei fatti
il motore di questo progetto
detto questo
vorrei inoltre sottolineare come questo
sia solo l'inizio di un percorso di
ricerca ancora lungo e volto a
sviluppare tecniche oltre sono grafiche
quantitative e dedicate alla diagnosi ed
al monitoraggio delle malattie polmonari
la buona notizia è che sappiamo dove
siamo
che strada percorrere abbiamo i mezzi
necessari per percorrere questa strada
ma di questo magari ne parliamo un'altra
volta
in conclusione ancora una volta si
dimostra come l'essenziale talvolta sia
invisibile agli occhi
e come forse la nostra dote più
importante sia la capacità di ascoltare
le cose con occhi con strumenti diversi
grazie